he only lived once so today we're going
to play do you know your favorite
artists real name the sudden-death pie
to the face quiz I'm going to give each
person 10 seconds to answer if they get
it right they can eat this delicious pie
if they get it wrong they've got to slam
their face into this pie
I don't really like pause but I do think
that I'm a master of trivia his stage
name is bono it's his real name John
O'Dwyer or Paul Hewson and the Donald
liar
that sounds very Irish to me the O in
there Simon I'm gonna go with Donald
wire wrong his stage name is the weekend
is his real name
Gabriel rodríguez-lópez or Abel Tesfaye
Abel Tesfaye cuz he dates Bella Hadid
who I'm in love with but I get to keep
the song maybe correct yeah
I'm like suddenly so nervous and tense
my mouth is dry her stage name is
Rihanna is her real name Robyn Fenty
or Ana Ravel there's no way that
Rihanna's last name is Rebelle and she
didn't make that part of her stage name
Rebell is too cool of a name she's just
like yo my name is rebel or like a
little rebel like that would be my rap
name correct Oh since I mean I don't
have to smash a pie in my face I get to
eat the pie I kind of want to smash it
in my face anyway I've never I've never
smashed a pie in my face is that okay I
love you Rihanna
that was good I know musicians names cuz
I like I like the realness I like the
truth her stage name is Taylor Swift is
her real name Taylor Swift or Taylor
Callahan
a sailor's left
right yeah it sounds left
correct I'm scared okay I'm ready this
stage name is Kendrick Lamar is his real
name
Kendrick Duckworth or Lamar Kendall oh
man Duckworth I don't know that I know
anybody with the last name Duckworth so
I'm thinking that I'm gonna go with the
second one wrong what what
Duckworth this is it's inside my nose if
I were a singer I'd probably go in with
a fake name too I'd be like Andromeda
and dropping it over to keep the corner
file to keep the jewelry as part of my
name but change Zach at the end drama to
Kornfeld